with nine films spread out over nearly
two decades and a release order that
jumps all around the chronological
timeline
it's fair if fast and furious fans need
a bit of a refresher
on where we wound up after each one
here's the ending of every fast and
furious film
explained despite functioning for most
of its run time as practically a beat
for b
point break remake the fast and the
furious notably diverges from the iconic
surfer thriller in its ending
while the 1991 film sees protagonist
johnny utah
release sympathetic antagonist bodhi
only to certain death
the fast and the furious has its law
enforcement hero brian o'connor
lets his law skirting frenemy go free he
even gives him an assist on his way out
after initially getting close to dominic
toretto only as a means to ferret out
the details
of his high-speed heist operation brian
eventually comes to realize that he
genuinely cares about dom and his crew
dom and his sister mia feel betrayed
when they learn brian's true identity
and subsequently attempt to cut ties
with him however brian chases dumb down
in a winner-takes-all quarter-mile race
with the implied stakes being that if he
wins don will cooperate with being
arrested
instead even though dom crashes his car
and brian wins the race
brian opts to give dom his own car
allowing him to escape
instead of arresting him the film ends
with dom driving free in mexico
and brian having chosen their friendship
over his career as a police officer
following his decision to facilitate
dom's escape at the end of the fast and
the furious
brian goes on the run making a living
competing in underground street races
eventually brian is arrested but cuts a
deal with the fbi to go undercover
and help bring down a drug lord in
exchange for a clean criminal record
to assist him brian recruits his
estranged childhood friend roman pearce
who is on parole and could use a similar
deal brian and roman take down the drug
lord with the help of u.s customs agent
monica fuentes
leading to his arrest and full pardons
for the two ex-convicts
unbeknownst to the fbi though roman sets
aside some of the drug lord's laundered
money for himself
although he does turn over the rest
three once more brian suggests the two
of them use the money to open a garage
together in miami
although that doesn't wind up happening
the only main fast and furious film not
a center around
darm or brian tokyo drift follows
teenager sean boswell who was sent to
tokyo to live with his dad after
destroying most of a residential
construction site in a drag race in
arizona
relocating to a different continent
doesn't do much to curb shawn's
speedster ways
and he quickly falls in love with the
japanese street racing scene
the japanese drivers all employ the
technique of drifting
which allows cars to maneuver around
curves and corners
using controlled skids after initially
failing at drifting
sean eventually masters the skill with
the help of a local racer named han
unfortunately not long after han has
taken sean under his wing
the yakuza come after han for stealing
from them a high speed chase ensues and
it appears that han is killed
the final act of tokyo drift sees sean
challenging a yakuza member's nephew to
a race
which will determine which of them is
allowed to remain safely in tokyo
using his newfound drifting skills sean
wins
now established as a drift king of tokyo
sean continues racing
and the film closes with an american
arriving to challenge him to a race
dominic taretto who claims that he used
to work with han
along with the next two films a fourth
film in the franchise
actually takes place between two fast
two furious and tokyo drift
after tokyo drift ended with the reveal
that darman han used to work together
fast and furious cuts back to that time
five years after the end of the first
film
the film opens with dom stealing fuel
tankers in the dominican republic
with a crew that includes han as well as
dom's girlfriend letty
meanwhile after getting his criminal
record expunged at the end of too fast
too furious
brian o'connor is now working as an fbi
agent
tom and brian's paths eventually cross
when dom hears that letty has been
killed and the search for her killer
leads him to a mexican drug lord
that brian is also attempting to track
down together the two team up to
apprehend the drug lord
and brian manages to arrest him with
dom's help in the process
dom kills one of the drug lord's
henchmen whom he blames felletti's death
making brian's attempts to clear his
name futile the film ends with dom being
sentenced to 25 years to life in prison
and able to accept this outcome brian
resigns from the fbi and teams up with
mir
along with a couple members of dom's
crew to break him out of prison
the film ends with brian leading a group
of cars into said to dom's prison burst
picking up directly on the heels of fast
and furious fast five opens with brian
and his accomplices breaking dumb out of
prison
together with mia they flee to rio de
janeiro by this time brian and mia have
rekindled their romance from the first
film
and during the course of the film mia
makes a game-changing revelation
we have no choice but to split up right
now in order to build a new life dom and
brian hatcher scheme to steal 100
million dollars from a major crime lord
which requires them to recruit a crew to
help pull off the heist
this includes han from tokyo drift and
roman from too fast to furious
along with tej giselle leo and santos
meanwhile diplomatic security service
agent luke hobbs and local brazilian
police officer
elena neves are in pursuit of brian and
dom
however after the crime lord's men
murder hobb's team he and elena agree to
join forces with brian and dom
to help with the heist in a
spectacularly destructive series of
events that involves dragging a safe
through the city
behind fast-moving cars the group is
successful in stealing the money
after killing the crime lord hobbs
agrees to give brian and dom a 24-hour
head start
provided they leave the money the duo
agree but
only because they've already secretly
swapped out the money the real loot is
divided amongst the crew
who scatter across the globe each with a
hefty pile of cash
at the end of the film a domino elena
who are now a couple relaxed on a beach
with
brian and mia meanwhile unbeknownst to
them monica fuentes from two fast two
furious
gives hub a file that shows that letty
is actually still alive
living large following their successful
heist at the end of fast five
dom's crew is eventually reunited by
luke hobbs
who reaches out to dom for assistance in
capturing a terrorist
named owen shaw working as a member of
shaw's crew isletty
who has completely lost her memories of
her life before she disappeared in the
fourth movie
motivated by a desire to find letty and
restore her memories
dom's crew teams up to track down shaw
although he eventually gets away
in the process dom saves letty's life
prompting her to decide to switch sides
and stay with him
the final act of the film sees dom's
crew pursuing shore to a runway
where dom's group is determined to keep
shore's plane from taking off
with its weapons of mass destruction
they're successful in stopping shore
but gisele is killed in the process of
saving han shaw is grievously injured
after being thrown from the plane
and is subsequently arrested by hubbs
who secures pardons for dom and his crew
as payment
for their assistance at the end of the
film although letty still doesn't have
her memories
elena graciously steps aside to allow
her and dom to be together
meanwhile a grieving han decides to take
his fast five money to tokyo
where he and giselle had once talked
about moving which is what puts him
there at the beginning of tokyo drift
in a mid-credits scene it is revealed
that the person whose car crashed into
han in that film was driven by owen
shaw's brother deckard
who is now seeking vengeance on the
people who injured and captured his
brother
the seventh fast and furious film picks
up just before the sixth film ends
showing deckard shaw stealing
information on dom's crew from hobbs
office
injuring hobbs in the process shortly
after that sure attacks han in tokyo
which we previously saw both in the
middle of tokyo drift
and at the end of fast and furious 6. as
short targets the rest of dom's crew a
mysterious government operative named mr
nobody
offers to help dom stop sure if dom's
team can assist him
mr nobody needs help recovering a
computer tracking program called god's
eye
as well as its creator a hacker named
ramsay who has been kidnapped by
terrorists
after rescuing ramsay dom's team manages
to help mr nobody stop the terrorists
and subdue sure
who is taken into custody by hobbs in
the process
leti finally regains her memories
revealing that she and dom
actually got married before they parted
ways in the fourth film
meanwhile mia has announced that she's
pregnant again
and brian decides that it's finally time
for him to walk away from his dangerous
life
in order to be with his family the film
ends with the crew bidding a bond
farewell to brian
as he drives off into the sunset and dom
thinking back on all the happy memories
they've shared together
this ending also served as an emotional
eulogy for paul walker
who died in an unrelated accident during
the film's production
after regaining her memories of their
wedding the eighth fast and furious film
opens with darman letty taking their
long overdue honeymoon in havana
unfortunately while they're there dom is
confronted by a cyber terrorist named
cipher
who blackmails him into betraying his
crew and helping her steal weapons
the rest of dom's crew along with hobbs
and surprisingly deckard shaw
are recruited by mr nobody to help them
stop cipher
eventually it's revealed that cipher has
captured elena and her infant son
it turns out that elena was pregnant
when she and dumb split up and she never
told him
however while outwardly cooperating with
cipher dom
quietly tries to undermine her which
leads to cipher having elena executed
ultimately though dom is able to get the
upper hand by helping the shaw brothers
mother
who repays the favour by tasking her
sons with rescuing dom sun
once the shores have recovered the baby
dom turns on cypher
thwarting her plans to incite nuclear
war and reassuring his team that he'd
never really turned on them after all
unfortunately though cypher manages to
escape before she can be apprehended
at the end of the film dumb finally
names his son while hobbs decides to
walk away from his job with the
diplomatic security service for good
everyone meet brian
following the events of the fate of the
furious decade shaw learns that his
sister
hattie has disappeared along with a
programmable super virus
and is tasked by the cia to team up with
hobbs in order to find her
once they locate hattie who was an mi6
agent they learned that she only
infected herself with the virus
in order to keep it from falling into
the hands of brixton law
a terrorist who has been cybernetically
augmented with super strength
brixton frames both shore siblings along
with hobbs as terrorists
and the trio flees to hobbs childhood
home in samoa to figure out their next
steps
there they prepare to make their stand
against brixton's organization
etion alongside hobb's brothers as they
work to defeat brixton and his soldiers
one of hobb's brothers figures out how
to extract the virus from hattie
even if the process is frustratingly
slow after his defeat
brixton is killed remotely by the unseen
director of etion
who then insinuates that they'll be
coming after hobson shaw
you don't remember me
you will it's gonna be a hell of a
reunion
however hobbs and shaw are unintimidated
by etion threats
the film ends with the shore siblings
breaking their mother out of prison
and hobbs learning about the existence
of another potentially even more
dangerous super virus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the fast and the furious films are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one